[music]
>> Alhamdulillah wal salat wal salam ala
rasulillah wa ala alihi wa sahbihi
ajmain am abad fa audhu billahi min
ash-shaytani rajim
Rabbi shrahli sadri wa yassirli amri
wahlul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu qawli.
Respected elders and my dear brothers in
Islam, I welcome all of you with the
Islamic greetings. Assalamualaikum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
May peace, mercy, and the blessing of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala of almighty
God be on all of you.
As you know, my name is Arshad Zagade.
And alhamdulillah
many of our brothers have gone through a
trials in their life. They were
non-Muslims and they reverted to Islam.
But alhamdulillah, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala gave
the hidayah to my parents. They were
Muslims, alhamdulillah.
And it was before even I was born, it
was a wish of my father that I will make
my child to work in the cause of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala before he was I was
born.
So alhamdulillah before I was at second
standard, I studied in a convent school.
But alhamdulillah, after that
I my parents got information about the
Islamic International School by Dr.
Zakir Naik.
And alhamdulillah, I got the admission
in the Islamic International School from
third standard. And it's a very
interesting story about how I got it
admission. It was impossible, but it
will take a lot of time.
Alhamdulillah, I completed my 12th
standard
from Islamic International School, my A
levels. And inshallah, I will be I have
applied Dr. Zakir Naik and I applied for
Imam Saud the university in Riyadh. And
in sha'a Allah, just pray for me that my
admission happens as soon as possible so
that I may gain knowledge of Islam and
spread this knowledge to the entire
world.
I mean
After completing my 12th
all of my friends and many of my
relatives, they asked me
like, "What are you going to do after
12th? Join some courses, join some
science class and everything."
But I had in mind that if I want to
dedicate my life
in the service of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala why should I pursue those fields
which are not concerned to me? For
example, they're telling me to do MBA. I
want But I want to do da'wah.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala opted for
me a third way, that is
to join Islamic Research Foundation.
Alhamdulillah. From past few months
I'm working as an employee in Islamic
Research Foundation.
And I've got to learn a thousand things
which I could have never learned in the
course of MBA.
Alhamdulillah.
Now it's a very interesting story that I
was an employee of IRF Islamic Research
Foundation. I have and I could have
never thought that I would be a part of
the DTP of the International Da'wah
Training Program.
I was Dr. Zakir Naik made me a DTP
coordinator as you may know that I was
sending the mails and SMS to you all. I
would never imagine that I would be a
part of you, but it's Allah's way to
his hidayah, his blessings from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala that eventually
yesterday morning he informed me that in
sha'a Allah I will be the part of the
Islamic Da'wah Training Program.
Alhamdulillah. So I pray to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala give us all the courage
the
um
the knowledge and the confidence and the
bearing capacity to engulf all these
Islamic teachings that Dr. Zakir Naik
and the complete IRF team has given us.
Wa alaikum da'wana alhamdulillah rabbil
alamin. Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
Alhamdulillah rabbil alamin wa salatu wa
salam asrafil anbiya wal mursalin wa ala
alihi wa sahbihi ajmain.
Mera naam Azlan Chan Hai.
And I
embraced Islam in the year 1986 when I
was in in school, a Christian school,
together with brother Kamaruddin.
And
um
for the past uh
maybe 10 years I've been doing uh da'wah
in Penang.
Uh three da'wahs. Uh
I I
I used to teach
Hokkien, which is uh a dialect in
Chinese,
uh so that da'ees will be able to
to converse with uh the Chinese in
Penang.
And
uh for the past I think 6 months I I'm
employed with uh the Malaysian Chinese
Muslim Association in
uh Kuala Lumpur
as a
mubaligh.
And um
um
I got a I got an offer to come to
Mumbai
and here I am.
Well,
uh
my hope is that uh I could uh
be a more effective da'ee
and uh will be to answer
to
my the
the non-Muslim which I meet, the mad
who's
uh
to provide them with a better
understanding of Islam and to
to clear the misconception of Islam
and
the Islamophobia
uh
to give them a clear picture
of the of Islam
of how beautiful is Islam.
Uh that's my intention to
come here and learn.
So
May Thum Say Pya Kal Ta Hom. Thank you
very much.
I welcome you all the brothers with
Islamic greeting. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi taala wabarakatuh.
My name is Abu Shariz Badar bin Sarajun
Huda. As you can see, I am from
Malaysia.
I graduated from Institute Chartered of
Shipbrokers London where I took a
professional qualifying examination in
year 2004.
I'm a
businessman. I have a shipping company
in Port Klang as well as I am a da'ee
an active da'ee where I am a volunteer
in Islamic Information Services
Foundation Kuala Lumpur as well as the
Deputy President of Squad Kadir
Selangor.
Therefore, I consider myself a
businessman, a full-time businessman, as
well as full-time da'ee.
Alhamdulillah, I had interest
in da'wah and Islam since a since a very
small age.
I'm a family person.
I find energy
from
you know, from my family, the motivation
from my family.
My wife, Hira Shahzad,
and my three lovely daughters, Tanzeel,
Sameen, and Rameen. I miss them very
much. At this very minute, there's a
wedding going on in my in my house. My
youngest brother is getting married.
But, call of da'wah is more important
than anything else, and alhamdulillah,
I'm here today leaving everybody behind.
The credit is not mine for my love in
da'wah and Islam. The credit is not
mine. The credit is my mom's and my
dad's.
Just like brother Ashfaq Zagade,
even when I was in the womb, my mother
used to dua that one day I I mean, when
I grow up
when I'm born and I grow up, I love
Islam and I become servant of Islam.
And here I am with the opportunity to
serve Islam because of my mother's dua.
The credit also goes to my father,
Sirajun Hoda. My mother's name was
Miss Nusrat Sultana from Lucknow, India.
My dad, Sirajun, he used to inspire
me by watching Ahmed Deedat's video. We
used to have all the collections of
Ahmed Deedat's video and invited guest
to home and watch these videos together.
From the age of 12, I developed the
interest and the motivation to become a
da'ee one day.
My best experience of my life
is Dr. Zakir Naik's Malaysian tour in
year 2012,
where alhamdulillah, I was the event
director.
With the help of 700 volunteers, we made
it happen.
Alhamdulillah, I was also the compare
and the host in most of the lectures.
It was a really, really memorable
experience, and I dua to Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala, will there be something
better than this? Could something better
be Something better than this can
happen? And alhamdulillah I've got I've
been selected now for this Dawah
program.
I'm being very emotional because I'm
really really happy and very very
honored
to be here.
I am born in India, Lucknow, Uttar
Pradesh. And often I'm being asked
where what is your background? Where
where actually you come from? What are
you?
And the beautiful answer which I always
give is that because I'm born in
Lucknow,
geographically I'm a Hindu.
Because I believe in praising Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, so technically I'm
also a Jew.
And since I'm a follower of Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
I'm also the followers of all the
prophets of Islam including Jesus
Christ, so I'm also a Christian.
And alhamdulillah summa alhamdulillah by
following the sunnah Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam, I am trying
to be
an honest
and practicing Muslim.
I thank
brother Zakir Naik and IRF
for the opportunity to be here today
to learn to be an effective da'ee
inshallah. With this
I end my introduction. Wa akhiru da'wana
alhamdulillah rabbil alameen.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi ta'ala wa
barakatuh.
La
ilaha illallah
la
Muhammadun
Rasulullah
Muhammadun [music]
>> [singing]
>> Rasulullah
arju ridhaka ya Allah antal raheemu ya
Allah habni ataka ya Allah antal kareemu
minka atao ya Allah antal adheemu ya
Allah fika rajao ya Allah antal haleemu
ya Allah ya Allah ya Allah ya Allah ya
Allah ya Allah ya Allah ya Allah ya
Allah ya Allah ya Allah
>> [music]
>> I understand
I understand